[音楽]
これがいいまあ俺ラーメン沿い
カップねー白石麺系とそうだね
どれ見たことありますいやーもう全部3頭と有名どころばかりですからね
即席麺の売り上げランキング top 体を用意しますおおなるほどなるほど
まだ3月ですね緑茶いますよね食べますねこの中でゴッドができる
はランキングなんて余裕ションってゆけんですよねっ
よああああおよよで却下さしかない
ネジいうことしかねってことだぜでもらえますちゃうよとにこれで1位から2やってれ
ばいいわけですよねまでも会津どうよ
別館んですよ同着的にもねそうだからまあ
1987ロックまでは去っん
はいペンギンは中からロケってみようかって言いだせ
鉄には19発だなロックててるゲッゲッいいねぇです
フォアうづっかなろぐねーってことで
じゃあからのか教えて時から5を当ててまあてなかったら
夏休みまではカプラー目禁止と
え
近津まで気づいてやれが行ういいんですよ
んですよねマネーカーやるけどレイヤーでけあるけどね渦に味見して1位から5位は
てればいいんですよ
ロス作っていきましょうおっぱいというわけできました
mother じっねこれがご注文ですこれでまあそろそろ夏盛り上げ max 売っ
てるにょ
逆には充電スーパーにとってことは先手必勝にまずいくつ星てって
まず旧宅に絞らせてください5つもりは1位から5位に入っていません
でが行けば大丈
ポイントとしてはまず味以前に販売店舗展開遺留物までおいしいんですけど僕んじゃの
時間でたトータル max まで進めてないんでまずはここでだぞするかなと正空経度
ね
なんでこれは言ってないんだよ
h 3んはないうちは甘いこれがそうですこれ一番ですって次行きましょうか
これはいう方ですねいただきます
それでペア6
50とに秋蕎麦好きなんだよ寒風に乗る彼食べてみましょう
これが当時べきかんじゃねぇ聞いて
いただきます
cme
まあ一つインコ2ついきます製フードヌードルは後にクッキング時世高3になっていた
ございません
[音楽]
女性でも楽しめる足のイメージですね本と音源もカリオストロの城で前にから来てる
イメージしかないですやってやつ
うまいんだけどやっぱしいうと食べすぎてこっちの好きなという jats にこちら
同盟ですねいただきマックスむらい
[音楽]
ゲーム一番前込んで馬続いて赤いきつねいきましょう
これがねまず食べなきゃだ
1名
じゃあ続いて緑のたぬき食べますこっちは天ぷらが入ってるのか
いただけますね
あツアー
母全然子です熱いラーメンで私減点しますか
気をつけていただければ最後これもランクインしてるのは順位の中にあんまり見たこと
ないねどん兵衛のに空洞ですなぜ見て食べるかモデル
ていません
[音楽]
ああありがとうございます
本当に本当に俺
[音楽]
ああ
うわぁ
ああああああ
あーできます
[音楽]
一番前や刷毛でこれリクードんという食べ物がこの世で一番美味しいのかもしれんっ
hell i still i カップラーメンねっ
頂点かあっああああああああ6いいからじゃあ発表してクロス第10位
ロスモリー大樹
にクローンを馬鹿じゃないのうって人が少ないと思うんですね
見たことないもんだよね第9位なる5つもりですね
[音楽]
ぺーアングですねまじ衝撃の結果だね第8位なる
意外とね有効現在8へ
念願の後つもりですここでランクインしてきますね
ここで早くも焼きそばスタで移る際7位
第7位はカップヌードルのカレーですね
正解ですまあまあはねっ
うん
[音楽]
[拍手]
おおーー
大間これは何加入としてはまあにアップ来ないカップだと思うんですけどそんなに下
カレーヌードルカフェで言っておけないと思ってロック位
はい当てていいですかはい緑のたぬきすごい
勢がいないで s 月いけるんちゃうおりちょっとちょっと気迫ったれてるのは今日
行けますね
出そろったが
いやこれ決めたら不味いラーメン牡4蔵王堂2号が残りましたねこれもういきなりに
ついから入っちゃっていうかまず知名度というかカップヌードルの原点にして頂点と
いう点を考えますのまつ毛でこのカップヌードルの基本的なタイプないってしまう受け
ていると思うんですその関連から言うとこれ一番安牌ではないでしょうか
カプで取り地位で株が1
[音楽]
正解ですまじウェッジ号米うち5位すごいみんな知ってるそのうんうん確かで俺すごい
結構いいよや幸せだからこれはもう水中で戦ったりなんですよ水中で泳ぐタイプなんだ
けど一人だけ明らか
陸上競技の選手がいるんですよ陸上競技の整理種
ヒューンとウつもりが思っている早めにランクがあったんで
ライトスタビじゃないかと思います ufo 第5位
[音楽]
とれません
ちょっと考えさせてください宇津井が
どん兵衛がね結構上の気もするんだけど
beaufort なんかもう22
第2杯言えばこれからスパイじゃなさ
第2話ん
ん
うん
wal
4コマニーかこれが並ぶことはないんでにツイートに良いですってそんなにすごいこと
ないかな本命なんかな
中居くんの cm してるから日本じゃな
ドンデー
兄は
[音楽]
バックデータのしてグラデー
ブーブーああ
[音楽]
ani よ
いや行けるわけですね意外
カップヌードル環境やさんやてぃさあいう方でしょ
ちゃいますで咲いた花エキスです4位5位
そえええ
どん兵衛が思ったより低くてびっくりしましたん食べてみて凄い美味しかったのに
8月31日までラー名は必至ですねラーメンくってるの見たよという方は今すぐ読めて
ない
お願いします
f
ラーメン中毒の症状が出てきちゃいますねただ動けますけれど
有働